my name is Maryann Bellotti and I'm a
software engineer right now I am working
with the Department of Commerce on
setting up technical SWAT teams but
today I want to talk to you about a lot
of work that I did for the past year for
an organization called the United States
digital service quick show of hands who
has ever heard of USGS ok how many
people have heard of you before before
you talk to me this week ok cool
alright so very briefly for those of you
never heard of us u.s. digital service
basically focuses on helping the
government provide better digital
services to citizens through technology
it's sometimes difficult for private
sector people to really understand why
government technology is so different is
so difficult like the government
invented the Internet so why does it
struggle so much in building websites
that operate on top of it especially
since they have access to talent and
almost infinite money but what we need
to understand about good user experience
and good digital services is that have
the way the private sector defines it
often by pushing boundaries in privacy
and security and and free markets that
are not appropriate for the government
to mimic so for example as a consumer I
love it that I can go to Amazon and
literally order anything I can possibly
think of but is it great for the economy
that all of that power is focused on one
company probably not I love that I can
go to Facebook and look up people I went
to high school with but is it great that
Facebook has all that data about me
probably not so a lot of times when I
come into a technical project in the
government the big thing that is is
creating all these blockers is actually
like legitimate concerns about what is
appropriate for the government to be
doing with data what is appropriate for
them to be collecting data and how they
should be configuring their systems for
optimum security so I think it's
important to understand that the men and
women of USGS are not geniuses we're
just people that are empowered to roam
across silos and across organizations to
diagnose technical problems and
ultimately find a resolution to them
tick trusted internet connection is a
really good example of this
fact so this is David David works for us
das before he came and worked for us he
was the head of engineering at OkCupid
and he comes up to me one day and he
says I'm working on this project and the
architecture that they telling me I have
to use it seems pretty insane and they
keep telling you that I have to use it
because there's a thing called trusted
internet connection basically it looks
like this we got our website is a AWS
and when people come from the public
Internet to this website they're not
allowed to go directly to AWS they must
go to a government data center and then
the government data center reverts the
connection up to AWS and he goes with
only one thing except we also backing
that web app have a dynamo database and
whenever the web app wants to talk to
the dynamo database it must read it's
connection through the government
database and then back to the dynamo TV
and he's like this is particularly
unusual because both the ec2 instance in
question and the DB in question are in
the same data center in Amazon Cloud so
why do we have to route connections out
of the data center to go back into the
data center and so he was to me has
anybody in USGS ever worked on tech
before is this a problem we can solve
and I was like well you already know
Brodie who we kind of poached from
stripes security team and there's
actually another person over at the VA
knew Aaron and Aaron's kind of
interesting case because he's actually
was a lawyer with the EPA and so a lot
of times when we're trying to diagnose
these technical issues we help people
who come and be like stop what you're
doing is illegal you can't do it and so
for us the most valuable people on our
team are this small group of lawyers
that kind of like swashbuckle in and go
no it's not illegal and then fence with
the the bureaucracy to like clear it out
of the way and so when we we originally
hired Aaron we thought that's what he
would do and then he showed up and it
turned out he also knew all this stuff
about computing networks despite having
no computer science on his resume
whatsoever and we were like well okay
we're gonna go with this you can go go
do that as well so I said so we got some
engineers there
work hard on these kind of issues and
have some experience and opinions on
them so let's get them together and by
the way the people in the office of the
federal CIO that work on technical
policy are aware that this policy is
broken and been trying to fix it
desperately for like three years so
let's go work with them too and see if
we can find a solution to it so that
brings us to the question what exactly
is a trusted internet connection so
trusted internet connection is a policy
that was written in 2007 essentially it
is an access point
what trusted internet connection policy
says is that whatever something on your
internal network wants to talk to
something external it has to go through
this very specific access point called a
tick and that access point will have
intrusion detection connected to it and
each agency can only have two it's a
sort of because the people wrote that
policy were the first to agree that it
was something of an arbitrary number and
you have agencies like NOAA and the FBI
that actually have a legitimate reason
to have more than two so it's all about
restricting access to government
networks and so the intrusion detection
systems that they're using are also
signature based not anomaly based some
of those signatures are classified but
they match they look at packets and they
match known threats known patters of
malicious activity so back in 2007 this
was not a terrible thing to do because
the internet looked completely different
in 2007 so for reference the iPhone had
just come out first generation there was
no app store so we're in the beginning
of the smartphone revolution but we're
not really very robust in the smartphone
revolution um
ec2 and s3 had just come out it would be
a year before Google and Microsoft
started to really move into the can the
commercial cloud market and people were
still somewhat skeptical about software
as a service it was still like yeah it's
a nice thing it might lower some costs
but don't put anything critical on it
the problem is that its 2017 it's a
decade later and how do you divine to
find perimeter security when your
perimeter has is basically dissolving in
of your eyes so you know how do you
define procurement or security when your
email which most organizations would
consider it an internal capacity is run
through Google Apps or Microsoft 65 when
you're using applications like concur
and Salesforce to do critical business
functions when your employees expect to
be able to work remotely particular your
technical ones when you're moving all of
your stuff out of a data center and on
to some sort of infrastructure as a
service like Amazon or Microsoft etc so
the way people deal with tich in 2017 is
by finessing the definition of internal
and external to somewhat insane degree
in theory external applications they're
not supposed to have sensitive
government data on them but what
sensitive government data actually means
is up for debate it's basically the
agency can has a lot of flexibility in
defining that there are some guide rails
for those of you are not familiar with
the landscape of government technology
there are two really important things to
understand FISMA and FedRAMP they're
kind of difficult to grok because they
sort of overlap a lot but the way I
think about it is that FISMA is how you
define the security level of a system
that you are building based on the type
of data that it's running and FedRAMP is
how we certify products and services
that other people are trying to sell you
as to whether they are equivalent to
that FISMA level so if you build a FISMA
moderate system then the architecture
that you buy from Amazon needs to be fit
so oops okay forgot one thing in
addition to that some agencies actually
have laws that Congress has passed
specifying how they handle their data
what they can and cannot do the two big
ones to know our title 13 which
specifies how the census can use the
data it collects on you and title 26
with specialized how the IRS can share
your data the IRS especially is very
good take this very very very seriously
so let's go back to this example what is
actually happening in this architecture
this architecture actually looks like
this where these two items are defined
as internal systems and these two items
are defined as external systems and so
as a result whenever an internal and
external system wants to talk they have
to talk through the ticke this is
another example we got a mobile
application we want it to talk to the
cloud if you've managed to define both
of these things as external or both of
these things as internal they can just
talk like this but there are many
situations in which you might say like
no our mobile applications are in fact
internal and our cloud environment is
external in which case they have to do
this or realistically speaking that
probably looks more like this so what
further complicates the situation with
tech is that most agencies when they
want to go on to the cloud they go on
with called Amazon's gov cloud this is a
specific data setter that amazon has set
up to handle the US government specific
security needs really the major
difference between gov cloud and normal
AWS is that gov called data centers are
staffed 100% by American citizens and
there are some differences in the
products that are available elastic load
balancer doesn't have the full range of
features that it does on AWS the
marketplace doesn't have the full range
of potential products and services to
use the agencies are also required to
use DHS's special classified intrusion
detection software so there's always
whenever we talk about reforming tech
policy that always comes up a lot and
we'll talk about that in more detail
later ticket self sort of creates a
false sense of security and not many
people understand exactly what it's
doing they just know that they are they
are instructed to use it and they are
instructed to use it for security
purposes so they tend to assume that
take in and of itself creates security
what all tick is is an access point and
because it's an access point that
everything is running through it also
creates a rather large single point of
failure at that the final complication
is that virtually all of our
raffiq is encrypted now and when you're
doing packet sniffing you're not really
getting that much information out of
encrypted traffic so the usefulness of
tick whatever usefulness it brought to
the table in 2007 it's somewhat
diminished by the fact that we're all
using encrypted connections so the first
thing that we thought about when we
thought about how can we change this
there are various workarounds that we
could use so for example both gmail and
outlook allow you to define a custom
mail server that outbound and inbound
traffic will be forward through so that
could give you a tech like functionality
for mail we also said like hey you know
what if you took away this two tick
limit and let agencies have lots and
lots of ticks we could actually build
government-wide
content delivery network and that could
be kind of cool and also kind of useful
the problem with that one is that at
least three administrations so far have
made it a priority to consolidate data
centers so it sort of flies in the face
of what the rest of the government is
trying to do they're trying to shut down
data centers and move to the cloud and
we would be saying no no put up more
data centers more ticks so that you can
go to the cloud in a different way the
other things that we looked at are uses
of virtual private clouds to further
manipulate the definition of an internal
versus external and actually the example
they put up on the board that's the main
reason why dynamodb was considered
external is because at the time that
they made that architectural decision
Dynamo didn't have full support for VP
C's I believe now that's no longer the
case so maybe they'll reconsider and
stop running all of their database
queries through their data center the
last thing that people sometimes use to
work around the tick is the concept of
peering and Direct Connect literally
running a cable from one machine to
another machine so that they're
communicating that way essentially the
challenge was figuring out if we want to
modernize this how are we going to
monetize it like there's two main
options we can throw everything that
tick is out and look at what's done in
the privacy
dr. now and just go from there which is
something completely new or we can
figure out how to virtualize the tech so
that we can move it into the cloud and
get the same benefit that is expected
from normal conventional tech but just
not have these crazy architectures where
we're going in and out of a data center
naturally the first thing we gravitated
towards was innovation particularly
because USGS has a lot of Engineers from
Google so they were very enthusiastic
about this they're like let's do the
beyond core thing zero trust networks
it's like it's the future Google
invented it it must be amazing it is
amazing and the problem with zero trust
networks well actually let me take a
step back for those of you who are not
familiar with what a zero trust network
is it's basically this idea that every
single thing that connects to your
network is potentially compromised and
so every single thing that communicates
with your network should communicate
over mutual TLS you should she use
multi-factor authentication on the user
you should have very strict access
controls for those users and you should
use good device management you should
basically run your network as if
everything on it is not trusted the
problem with this and the government is
that it relies really heavily on PKI
which is something that government has
struggled with for the last couple years
so in 2004 there a Homeland Security
presidential directive 12 came out which
basically said hey everybody let's do
secure IDs let's use credentials make
them government-wide make them super
easy to sort of like use from agency to
agency let's get this done and seven
years later the Government
Accountability Office which is
Department under Congress had reported
that they had made a lot of progress
with this but it had not yet been fully
implemented and actually at USGS there's
a bit of a running gag about how many
badges can you really collect in the
government as you go from project to
project to project because none of our
badges are actually compatible with one
another I have three I would have four
except the DoD would not give me one
unless I
to work for them for six months and I
was like you know what I'm okay with
having really cute soldiers X court me
everywhere I go that's fine so another
problem that we have with the zero trust
network is that engineering groups the
government are frequently very heavily
siloed from one another not just the
traditional wall between development and
operations but also development groups
are very heavily separated from one
another and operations groups may be
siloed as well and so what happens in
that kind of environment is that one
engineering group is trying to build a
thing needs access to something that
another engineering group owns can't
manage to negotiate how they get access
so they start looking for cheap
workarounds or just quick fixes which in
this kind of environment injects a lot
of security vulnerabilities right so
what's important to understand about
this is that we generally think about
user design as a front-end issue we
generally think about user design as
being something that's about making
things pretty but in my opinion user
design is actually even more important
when we're talking about network
security because if people don't
understand what makes the network secure
or how to use the network effectively or
how to like work those access controls
then they will ultimately try to violate
the access controls and then you don't
have security so the reason why we put
this aside is because we didn't believe
that every single agency in the
government was capable of implementing
it in a way that was safe and secure so
we went back to the concept of the tech
itself and we thought like how do we
virtualize this and then we hit the
first big barrier which is like you
can't put the tick in the cloud because
Amazon won't buy it won't build us a
skiff so for those of you who are not
familiar with the term skiff it is
essentially a room where you can discuss
classified information I know what
you're thinking you're imagining like
huge monitors full of like complex data
visualizations and like war room type
scenarios but most skiffs are the most
boring conference room you've ever been
in your life beige paint on the walls no
windows no like decor of any kind it is
simply a room where you can discuss
classified materials
and the reason why this is a problem is
because the ticke reference architecture
says that there must be a skiff
30 minutes away from what's called a
tick management location and most people
assume that what a tick management
location is is the data center
so most people interpret that directive
in the reference architecture to mean
that there must be a skiff 30 minutes
away from your data center however the
tick reference architecture actually
never defines what a tech management
location is it never says it's a data
center what it says about it are the
following things the first thing that it
says is that it must be an exclusive
space it must be staffed 24 hours
it must be 30 minutes from ask if a
little side note to that they never
defined 30 minutes by what so we were
kind of like 30 minute walk a 30 minute
drive a 30 minute HTTP request like what
are we talking about here oh and then
the last thing it says is that obvious
people must have remote access so
everyone as soon as it means this skiff
in a data center but it could actually
very legitimately mean this just a
government building where you already
have asked if you manage you use the the
the api's to manage your tick at your
tick management location remotely so
then we came across like the the big
barrier the thing that has probably
killed every attempt to reform tech so
far and that is you can't put classified
signatures in the cloud and you
especially can't put classified
signatures in a cloud that you don't own
and so my reaction to this was sort of
like but why do we need to put
classified signatures in the cloud so a
little backstory about this the program
that I'm referencing here is called
Einstein and essentially it is an
intrusion detection system that is built
by and maintained by DHS it takes
classified signatures and monitors web
traffic will monitors all sorts of
traffic on and off all sorts of
government networks across all agencies
and in 2016 Government Accountability
Office said sort of like
you know what they're actually doing a
really good job blocking malicious email
traffic they're doing a good job
blocking malicious DNS but they are not
doing anything to block web traffic it
doesn't block web traffic at all in fact
and deatrice his own documentation sort
of specifies that Einstein is really
about situational awareness do you HS
have this problem they were being asked
by Congress and by the executive branch
to basically monitor cyber warfare and
like fight fires around the government
but when an agency was attacked they
generally would not report the incident
to ghs so they needed a way to sort of
automate that information so that they
didn't have to like go to the agency and
require the agency to like follow the
rules and report these things
effectively and so one of the problems
that Einstein presents is not what it is
or even the effectiveness of what it is
it's the idea of what it could do in the
future
everyone gets very very excited about
the Einstein of tomorrow which will have
all of these bells and all of these
whistles and fireworks will go off
around it like you read the
documentation on Einstein and DHS will
say like in the future we will be able
to block web traffic in the future we
will do this in the future we will do
that but that kind of overlooks the fact
that this doesn't actually exist yet
right we have the Einstein of today so
one of the most important things we did
in this process is actually just refocus
the conversation and say like you know
what we will deal with Einstein of the
future in the future when the seventh
seal is broken and Einstein descends and
like saves all of our problems then yes
we will make sure that whatever
technology we're running integrates
perfectly with it and provides Einstein
with whatever Einstein needs to get the
job done but we're living in the today
so let's deal with the Einstein of today
and make sure that what we're proposing
works with the Einstein of today so what
does that actually mean a lot of times
in these kind of technical conversations
they're a bit like negotiations and in
negotiations it's really important to
sort of understand what is important for
you to advance your goal what your
negotiation position is and what their
negotiating position is so what does
Einstein actually need to do the job
that is currently doing it needs
visibility
it needs data it needs to be able to
alert agencies when it detects a problem
and it needs data feeds so that it can
do government-wide intelligence
what is USD s concern about us yes is
USGS concerned about email security not
really
I mean look we're pretty happy with the
government's current email security
probably could be better but you know
like seems to get the job done we don't
really have many complaints about that
it's the u.s. just concerned about
government network security I mean if
there's a problem we'll come help out
but it's not really our mandate it's not
really what we're passionate about it's
not what we came to DC to do the thing
we're really concerned about is the
public facing website so that's
something that I would say a lot again
and again and again is that well we're
interested in and we're gonna push based
on this interest in getting government
public facing government websites to be
a scalable and performance and secure as
possible
so everything that I say is in that
frame of mind and if there is some
reason why what we want to do won't work
for your factors then let's bring that
to the table and discuss it so when we
got DHS to agree that all they just
needed was visibility into the traffic
and a way to alert agencies the question
became can't we just mirror the packets
from the cloud to Einstein why do we
have to move Einstein to the cloud let's
leave Einstein where it is and just send
a copy of the traffic over to Einstein
and so surprised everybody when DHS came
back and they said yeah that might
actually work if you want to do that if
you want to try that out that seems like
it might work so then we got to this
question of like okay how do we do that
so probably the most obvious way to
mirror traffic is on a switch the
problem with that is that Amazon is not
going to let you access their switches
it's just not going to happen so it's
not particularly cloud friendly and then
depending on the way that you choose it
to do so you might end up dropping
packets which will not make DHS
particularly happy so another way you
could think about doing it is on the
router and actually Amazon does offer
the possibility to do gateway routers
that do have a certain amount of
configuration options to them but that's
sort of Amazon specific there's no
guarantee that other call options are
going to
for the same services or you're going to
expose the same configuration settings
so the thing that we sort of settled on
was we can do it on the VM level we can
do with IP tables but the trade-off
there is that that adds a lot of
overhead to your your image right it
adds a lot of overhead to your instance
it's not cheap so when we thought about
that we thought well we already have an
image that we're running all our traffic
through it's called a load balancer and
little balancers reasonably white
lightweight so what if we did this what
if we virtualized the tech and we just
made it a little balancer that mirrored
traffic off to Einstein where DHS can
analyze it is that a thing that's gonna
work and so for our perspective there is
a lot of stuff we have left to sort out
we don't exactly know what the load
leave resource to load the resource load
on the VMS is gonna be from doing this
and more importantly if you don't
exactly know what the load on the
network is gonna be like mirroring
traffic is not particularly cheap so we
have to figure out like does that even
work in a cloud environment and the last
thing is that we probably want to be
able to encrypt this traffic right we
got to figure out how that's gonna
happen but more importantly we also want
to figure out how we can make sure that
this whatever this ends up looking like
it adds the most value to government
agencies we don't want government people
to just be focusing on using this thing
because it improves their compliance we
want them to focus on using this thing
because it increases their security
increases their performance we wanted to
have legitimate value add so we look at
this idea that we know for a fact that
cloud the go clouds the lock to elastic
load balancer doesn't have the full
array of features of AWS is the elastic
load balancer and we can look for where
things are lacking and see if we can
design a technical solution that brings
some of that stuff into this new model
and lastly zero trust networks are not
the right solution right now but they
are the future and who knows what ten
years for now this is gonna look like
we're not going to see a stop in how
networks parameters are
dissolving like the more we integrate
technology into our lives and the way we
work the more these issues are going to
continue to expand and degrade the
concept of a network perimeter so at
some point we have to start getting the
government to move over to something
that they can eventually jump off and
hit at zero trust Network because
reasonably speaking that's probably what
things are going to look like going
forward so how can we use this as an
opportunity to get them headed in the
right direction so that as things as
that that aspect of technology matures
they're able to evolve with it so I see
there's the question of like why exactly
is this so hard
it amazed me when I was sitting and
having a conversation with DHS and I
brought up the the concept of packet
mirroring how easy that conversation was
and I had this moment where I was like
you're telling me five years and like
hundreds of Engineers no one has ever
suggested to you that perhaps we could
just mirror the traffic over like that's
the way intrusion detection works in the
first place but these things are hard
because there's a lot of like mental
separation that has to to go into the
way you examine the the problem itself
so when tech policy was originally
written in 2007 it merged the concepts
of software as-a-service cloud hosting
and mobile devices it treated them as if
they were all the same they're not all
the same they've grown into like
completely different things that require
a completely different security attitude
and perspective so in order to fix the
policy people have to become aware of
that fact they have to separate these
policies out and treat them differently
also getting people to separate their
current needs from their future needs
from their wish lists it's this takes a
lot of like careful conversation we had
to have the same conversation with the
same people over and over and over again
just to make sure that we were all on
the same page and we're all defining
things correctly the people who are good
at writing policy and the people who
have technical expertise are rarely the
same people I've learned a lot of really
interesting things about writing policy
and like Oxford commas and like how you
should never use n slash or in a policy
because it's kind of counter to
see there in end or its or but I've also
taught a lot of things about like how
technology works how networks work what
you can do with the cloud it's really
about making sure that these people are
able to find each other because
sometimes they have trouble finding each
other and the policymakers can't write
good policy if they don't have good
technical advice
lastly the best if the best solution
can't be understood by its users it's
not a solution and I've just now
realized there's a typo in my slides
this fairly hilarious you know you you
work on something for a certain period
of time and it's you never you never
catch anything
alright so leave it if the best solution
can't be understood by its users it's
not the right solution so what's our
current status here the tick working
group output contributed to a memo that
was put out by the office of American
innovation actually I take that back the
memo is not officially put out it has
just closed public commentary so you can
go online and you can read the draft but
it's not officially out until it gets
until they Judah Kate all of the
comments by the way they do this on
github it's fairly cool so we our output
was contributed to the Office of
American innovations IT modernization
strategy and that report basically said
hey you know what let's start
experimenting with some of these ideas
let's take a few projects at a few
agencies and just kind of take the leash
off and say like alright if you wanted
to do tick for the modern a and show us
what you would do and let's collect data
and figure out what the policy should
look like going forward the acting
federal CIO has basically put tech
policy as one of the top priorities for
the stuff she wants to fix going forward
so I have to have a little bit of extra
time which is cool so I'm going to a
little side commentary about why policy
not necessarily specifically tech policy
it's so difficult to do so this is
generally what policy how policy gets
written it gets drafted then it gets
sent out to agencies for comment then it
gets into the lawyers who pay
Nitz like you wouldn't believe and then
they get sent out to the public for
public commentary and this all looks
very simple and very intuitive except
that at any point in time if there is
something highlighted that's serious it
kind of resets itself and you go back to
the beginning and then you get into this
fun conversation of exactly how many
agencies are there in the federal
government you have no idea how hard a
question this is to answer Oh
officially there are watching 24 CFO act
agencies so you can think of those as
the big ones Department of Defense
Department of Treasury so on and so
forth but if you start breaking down all
the little ones you could get anywhere
from like a hundred to four hundred and
then you have these fun conversations
about like so does Freddie Beck and like
Fannie Mae have an opinion on this
all these little like things that
straddle the lines between private
sector and government and then when you
get up to the public commentary section
you have to remember that when we say
public commentary we mean individuals
like you like you are welcome to make
comments on government policy but more
likely you mean corporations and
lobbyists who do not write short
comments I might add so for a little bit
of fun let me show you this is Google's
public comment on the eyewall okay that
did not work but I have a lovely desktop
don't I no no okay well I can't show you
here it is mirroring displays no it's
alright
I was going to show you Google's comment
you can actually go to GSA's github IT
modernization into the comments section
and download it for yourself but it's
like about two to three pages of Google
advertising how great all of their
products and services are followed by
two pages of comments on what the actual
policy was and when you read the
corporation comments they're all
basically like that it's like so here's
a background in which we tell you why
you should give us all the money to fix
all the problems that you've high
and oh by the way we have some comments
on your actual policy so I'm about at
the end of my time thank you so much for
listening if you guys have any questions
we set up a civic tech channel on the
slack you can ping me maryanne or you
can just hunt me down that's cool too
thanks
[Applause]